[音楽]
本日は遊び社長です
というわけで
ワクチンも2回打ったということで完全に
安全とは言い切れないんですけども
ちょっとため気に入ってくる機会があり
まして富山県の私始めそれが住んでた
高岡西高校という私の暴行に帰ってきまし
たーー
どうせが健介なん
まあだろうねなんできたかといいますと
なんと私の母校の高岡西高とがですね来年
本年度いっぱいで他の皇后と逃亡になって
なくなってしまうということになって
しまいました
まじ悲しいよめっちゃ悲しいを俺の青春の
3年間を過ごした場所ですからここでなん
かすごいありがたいことにですね
その高校最後のジョージと言いますか
イベントにちょっとお呼ばれさせて
いただいて今回僕の母校の西湖に来てる
わけなんですけどもあの僕のバスケ部の一
個上の先輩だった
中野先輩がですねこの高校には京商されて
いるということでどうぞ
[音楽]
くださいございますよろしくお願いします
本当にバスケ部だった時の一個上の先輩で
今この母校で占領されているということ
ですねドンヘ僕の印象は
英文のいしこ
お願い結構部バスケで結構一緒にして
まったもんそう
んでないんで本当に乗ったもうちょっと術
語ったじゃないですかいやあのそうでも中
で壮大な狩野さんもなんかめっちゃを去れ
ば先輩で何かチャラいんだけど生徒が入っ
たかもやってたって言うまでも正当化
やっぱ者が一緒にセットパパ忠雄さんが
ございました俺だけの向こうがオーナーん
つぶる統合車頭を集めるではない部分
今生徒さんでどうなってるんですよ今
1爆燃部だけちょっと新しいテープさん
とって言ってないからいないそっかーさー
マイクロなぜ3クラスで中学年だから
120人弱ぐらい弱ぐらいぞそっかー学校
自体のペイントさんが少ないのも悲しい
るっ
上ないん
ちょっと思い出に浸りながら今触っていき
たいとおもいます
なんかすごい票ですアリエル
きましたがの黄色い星
俺が始めはじめシャツ待ってるなーって
いきますかそれに俺はここから登校生倒さ
こっちかな
とってから来悪いて後期型
3つの方言かんですか家がーあーちょっと
もっ
歩いさあ12年生そうださん寝て今ね
抱っこねーっ
見てみて何もないそんなルールがあるんだ
そう
懐かしいも記憶がよみがえったああああっ
しかしこの
win ぞでこれ前で言ってられるんです
よ全員されたらた顔が行き
チャリの鍵なくして皆探し滝を軽くなるん
今後に食べて一番遠くねぇそこ行っちゃう
んだろうな
後から出てくるからああ
酷寒でできてすぐココに乗って彼の
まっすぐ帰ってあーなるほどねここへの
かっぱでよかったよ一歩進む
な強いやったった権力でやったね改めてた
ちょっと今これやっていたのか
あ抜きで帰るときは
めんどい座長もまでこの子だって帰ら
なきゃいけないわけですよ
鉄鋼などがこと面材時は重い
[音楽]
はっはっは
そうですねいやーこれはよろしくないです
ね
うわっ
ん
ちょっと覚えていて懐かしいやばいん
aiff ちゃんとあるのだあいつある
うわぁ
会津合わせる山田これぞうわ懐かしいやめ
やめこの丘ネジさあ白パン目
回転も倒すと
回転して補正やつのところでお金を入れて
あげるっていう
ベルギー紙からんトコロ
だったら今これで体を上げ店にもってに
入ったお金は取られる側だったのであと一
の鍵とがここに入れて締めて回転させると
かという技マ確かだかないった130円
入れないかけて1階ですけどとこれはもう
10年前からずつ揉んでるんでしょ
距離なかったらこんな高級する
低糖質プリンなんで食べる高校生ですか
これ
ブスのロッカーに入れてた六花なくなっ
てるじゃないですか
ああああああああ
[音楽]
4日あった6静岡にこうやって撮った入る
だけでもなんかいい
perfume の別荘
あのバスケ部は1年生の tips 入っ
たダメっていうなどのルールがあってこの
1本で着替えを買ったちょっとですよね一
年草ですよね
ここが1年ショート室ここでバスケ部一年
はこういう敵以外2
願っパレー部助手とかのちょっとエロい人
を覚えてい
でたねそれが皆聖書この感じ幌
6分
バドミントンとかバレーちょしての
ちょっと薄い服の人をここで見てたって
いう
ブーバー女子からワンちゃん下がれば
シャロンあるほど
スカ撃っ
usn ありますからねえ
us こんなビー
これ畑の上になってるんだスモーカーに
開く
ん
すっごい貼ったのは俺だってきます
活性ていただけ100円ショップで売って
だから八田てがトルコの発送料秒ぶー認め
ず堂々じゃないのにすごいね
すごいん
こっちから3年性能買ってるよ
3新潟3年で2個あってきてはくれてるん
ですよせいじゃん
役金服も入った109
いやでもこのロッカーまず懐かしい
待っているのですなごりあるネタやイェイ
政治のポスター貼ってがますなーっと思い
ます
なしバストイレ
本当だますから薄々これもぬ傘踊りさ
やっぱりぽいぽいぽい俺はきますのハート
大丈夫大阪ウィッグみんなで送信してね
hnz ニー m に@ docomo .
ne . jp 俺のウェア度が昔のじゃ
バイ
中はない今中野さんの字も書いて
ありがとうございました
[音楽]
こういうことをやる5の差を
確かにパッ日ですあんまり変わってない
変わってない各が s なん
代わって
ずっと叫んでいるか県でいようっ
グランドもチェスター
ん
さっきえーい
ぜってー使え目からここマジで本当に開け
んでいいですから俺が妹のご存じでは妹な
感じです
めっちゃキレーヌっチェキでいきたいは
もう
バドミントンがもう何か仕掛けたいけど出
てますもんビシッ
変種と毎年同じかと思っいう風
もう年間日本トッププレーヤーに向かって
ますすると何で世界プレイヤーが部下とし
てるわけですバスケットボール飛んでた時
の
風紀がヤバすぎて本当に
ん
ブーシュ2分イタリアがどうするー
経験
塩鍋サブタイのは定番と雇用
いい
ギアスの付け方が間違っている格好で
こんな事を言い各
まくったからねぼく生徒だったれま
1回ちょっと食に強います俺は図5ホーム
でした
ここです
ここだここで水を受けた方じゃないでしょ
なんか皆さん覚え入ってますよねめっちゃ
彼女と仲良かったんじゃないん
4 nその彼女が選挙そこだった
曽祖父はいえ嘘のアングレイもいなぁここ
だったこの一関係弾でしたらめっちゃ一緒
に登校してませんです完成
実は高校生かと部活と補助に行ったり一番
いいじゃないですか
あったよずう年前ですよねもう
ちょうど良くなかった
ana
いならぁぁ
うわぁ
[音楽]
なった
ちょっと待ってます
月危ないからバエ丸バエん
敗北はこの高岡西高校で3年間勉強部活
恋愛
すべてを一生懸命頑張ることの大切さを
学ばせていただきましたもうなんかなく
なると思ってなかったから自分の高校が
この戻る場所がなくなる寂しさとかもある
んですけどもここで学んだことは僕の中に
一生残り続けると思ってます
みんな先週は人生で一度きりだから学校生
が楽しんでね
ヒート vivo
閉じレバー
あなたがああ
歌の
いるこそねえ
ano
うなれたでしょう